お笑い芸人メス h ばバスケたユーザー
[拍手]
releasenote
同3冊中で3皿の形でマソニアドレーサーをタグカー s
五條シューティングは売りです朝鮮人黒人順です
会本部場です
2ちゃんねる代表ですビリーそして
麒麟田村です悪いですつまります
[音楽]
ブーバー割としっかりパス家経営者はから詰めてきてますんで
ん
えっ
なんだ俺なったと実際に試合みたいなもしてみるとどうなるのかっていうのは今日行っ
てみたいと思うんだろうがもうこっちは月でいいですか
もうこっちの勝ちなんですよ今日はよろしくねございまーうわぁ
んだかルールなんですけどはい4答えると長くてみられないと思うんね以降探知 ok
だよ10分を2回
ok よろしくお願いしまーす
早速試合していきましょう
てくれん
ええええええ
pham
ラーメンの話だけどのかあさーんないですね
飯山市印旛村開拓だよ好きなは恋愛が着ぶせず普通は塗って
しかしてますか
ん
dee
ゆチューバつよいぞああ
あああああこらああああ
youtube の世界に殴り込み者
[拍手]
の
本町ミスお願い a year
[拍手]
てやれないことはないという想いを空
ここにもって
例えばああ
言われたあああ
アレルギー科ん
aname
さあバスケ好きユーチューバーそしてバスケ好きお笑い芸にそれぞれの意地とプライド
を懸けた一戦をお伝えいたします
間もなく試合が始まりますこの試合の実況私柴田そして解説には試合にも出場された肇
社長ですはいよろしくお願いもよろしくお願いしますさあ試合が始まりました
まずは右サイドから攻めていこうというところですお笑い芸人
チームファスナーわたって中央田村さん
やたらたやっぱ腰椎ですねやはり出力がある
はいこの秋冬 cc んでした
方はなんとが我々のボールにできました a さユーチューバーチームこっから攻めて
いきます
はい神田の視力が結構困り着替えちゃんでええこと僕がどう絡めるから
創部のか気にならないとこの今肇社長から
水たまり今度カンターここはつながりません足に当たりましたね相手に当たってボール
が出ました
作家じゃありませんからはい
スタッフと払っていきますここはリングに嫌われまず挨拶といった所へ行っ
今の挨拶のシリーズそうですねそうなんですね
スタジオから展開して今切削さらにされて元はいさーそして遠目からあったシュートが
決まりましたまず先生テーマお笑い芸人チームですあっあーっ行ったちょっと早速です
ねうーんまいっすよねー
同じ動産が初回ドーンと数
そしてもう一度館た同盟から狙えますここは決めることができません
マーチシュートで終わればいいと思います大事なことですねはい
さ再びお笑い芸人チームのオフェンスになります
中央麒麟の田村から左サイド先ほど3本で決めているがこれはこれを
決まりましたなれ
や者道
俺は大差での試合になってしまうでしょうか
内心ちょっと泣きかけてましたからねまあそうなんですがその初めてのゴール持ってい
ます
中東決めました素晴らしいよ嫌になりませんでした
これはどうでした決めて標準価格差路結構ミドルシュートと p なんでああああ
それぞれ僕の良いですねうーんまたーーりまたーー
深海からシルクへさぁ全然特徴
そのままシューター私は簡単がとって再びもう一度
これが決まりますがたいですねやはりカンター素晴らしいプレーを見せてきますねー
羽編集好きですからはいきっちりしたプレーが得意なんですよねなるほど
さあそして中央麒麟の田村これは誰かが鍵
花形でねやはりもう隙を見せると次々にシュートを放ってくるという笑い芸人チーム
寂しそうやっぱこれやりましたねやっちゃいましたねすごい気分的な場面ですねー
さあ中央から再び笑い芸人左歳同士の田村さん
これは暇はないもう一度キープしたともう一度麒麟の田村のシュート
ブーン
いやー立て続けに住めぽいできますねやっぱ頭です通学生がよ
生きてるんですかねぇもうその頃の経験がこのバス停でも生きてると思うようなプレー
が
さあそしてカウンター今度はユーチューバーの攻撃間とさん
そしてはじめもボールを要求しているそのはじめ所
このうちカッターどうですか播磨のニャーインジェラポッキーでしたバレット
相手は全くキューピーまでしタイマー画面外から飛び出してくるような動きでそのまま
得点をしていきました
そしてまた再び麒麟の田村というところですトリッキーなショットでしたねー
これで6体経営お笑い芸人人が三点リーダーそして再びカンター前へ
スピーディーなプレーを見せていきます
さあ始めましょうおですねちょっと疲れたので休憩します
ちょっと何かこうカッコつけているようになりますが彼だいーでー
うそのままの外れるとん
どれでお笑い芸人ボールに変わっていきます
右サイドを使う
さあやや緩急をつけながら左サイドを狙っていきます
これが外れる主力がとって3ポイントが甘いです相手は確実にこの
狙ってくるという
危ないシーンを作っていきますそしてはじめ車場ですこの12番
と食べて実写ずシルクもう一度はじめ
ホワイトさんら伊藤さんから方
僕はシュートなかなか速い遠目から打っていきますこれ
あります素晴らしい柔道ありがとうござい
かっこいいそうね見せていきますて10分にをちゃんと持ってたいなと思いましてこれ
はもう来月のバレンタインも非常に楽しみなところですねはーいですからそうですねー
これだからそれが何だからぁーここからそのまま自分でこじ開けて生きられだ
これで11第9です再びリードすっげードリブル低くて止めれないんですよねー
うまいんだなぁそうですねもうバスケを最近もかなりやり込んでいるというその麒麟の
田村さんです3たらピントから盛んでなくていきますがこれが決まらないもう一度
カウンター
バイオ例の終止着信ですて難いですね執着しています
さあ左サイドお笑い芸人ちん再び異聞11対11にしてという入っ
あればシーン奪えるか
俺の神明様々でそりゃあ
シルクへ all by に行きますが僕はも椅子ください
じゃあ残り5分ですねここまでこの前戦ってみてがだったでしょうか皆さん
じゃあ行ったためらさんが非常にうまいんですけどうちのチームもしっかり動けてるん
でまあいい試合運びにはなっているからといったところですねええ
ただやっぱりアイテム3ポイントが最写真で
羽立をつけたいなとですねはいあー気をつけなければいけない
そしてメンバーチェンジがありましたこの糸というのはハイあの動画的に前いたしたい
なと思いました様ですかはい
大腸チャンネル生が僕ということでちょっと投げ僕だけ残ってくれますね
疲れてるのいかがですかもう限界ですてあげたいですが現時点でこの試合は第1
クオーター10分そしてジャイ2クオーター10分の計20分で争っていきますはい
そしてご覧くださいはい相手 jma 女性のプレイヤーがいますよ
61番という今右士
サイドに見えていますがちょっととかアイドルなんですよあそうなんですか
尺品かられ地元坂野はいアイドルらしくて
期待の若手芸人さんということですねアイドルほんとファーがしづらいだとそうですね
女性ですしなかなか
強硬なプレーというのはなかなかできないかも知れませんそんな中で初めて招集超お
話します得意なところでしたこれは基板ない
その女性プレイやっておりますてあぁ可愛い筆つい外してしまいがあるんですっ
三藤見とれちゃうかんでしょうね
ブーブーいきました sonar 13敗11これユーチューバーチームリーダーです
サー女性プレイヤーアイドルもしているというこちらのプレイヤーからパスが出てもう
一度そのプレイ夫はこれ
油位俺ああ
あっはーなーリコー強気に行きましたお姉さん無料じゃないとと栄養士がありません
でしたね
激しいですねー
さあ船プレイヤーって
再び終わらユニ中から
ボール入っていきます中央
わざわざつまらない
催事はチャスなるを奪流れ同名な花といった
jose
そしてもう一度バスを回して
決めていました言われ4点差ですはいこここれは彼とした香りがしたんだよね
愚直社会人としてユーチューバーとしていけませんでこれはこれでねちょっと次回から
しかに来ていただきたいと思う
さあ田村のカレーネットに書いてもいいですからですねできるだけ点を取ってほしい
ところです
zard ないを決めていきました再び2点差です
プロフィールないが暑苦しいですねそうあほロアー写真の話ですね
ここで北へチェンジではい
これで煩雑な3階入っていくとリースプレストゥーの世界でもかなり
トップレベルのローラー使いというかそうなんですね
このバスケの実力はどうかというところが今日は試されます早速声が当たりました
さあいったんはを取ってから遠目からやっていきました
さあもう帰ってきてお笑い芸人のボールになります
早いですねやはりへこれ速攻を仕掛けていきますねー
粗糖6第2第3の使うそしてシュートを払っていきますそれかとだ
どうだかわいいこれは事前メイヤーいいですね
さあ麒麟の田村から左サイドそして遠目から
これがなかなか決まらないすべてないこれた皆さんに見えると思うんですけどあまりと
違う人だねもう変わってるんですねあいやバンドが
たお腹に見えましたがなお連盟4.3になりましたユーチューバーチーム
開きましたねこれしっかりとゲームのほかにもこのバスケットでもしっかり結果を残し
ていきました
ん
さあ17対13で残り2分
ら1クオーターも残り2分になっていますもうちょっと点差話したいところですねー
ここは肇社長休んでいるというね入るんですけれども後半に向けてね
しっかりと安いでほしいところです
これ広がりますほぼ河童ですからね彼
この魂さんですはい保木パ木パープレーがいパープレーでセンター強いと
ただこれ見方だと楽しいですねえよねぇーんじゃあポッター
さんもう一度ユーチューバー前世につながったあー
自分が普段はお願いしましたこれはいけません
ここもいけませんは大チャンスを外してしまいました
早いですねやっぱり愛車の展開が硬毛連携という音れてますよねー
チームですからねきたトメから狙っていきますこれがイランと大敗
そして
もう一度でも無駄
ました力強いですねー
4点差になります
これも本当に接戦ですねーいい試合ですね
ファー残り1分になります第1項ちゃんも残りわずかになってきました
右サイドから繋がって樹
さあどうだ有事はトーベさん狙っていきますこれ
どんなものをとって一旦ここはタメをつくってから逆細動
入るかシェイと入れませんだ少しくお疲れもね見えているような感じがしますね一旦攻
魔を取るような時間が増えてきました
ですね
我々値段編集してますから
体力という部分がまあネックになるとかなでんだサートって
カウンターさあ仕掛けていく
パスを回して決めましたこれにいる1点6点3になりますユーチューバーチームりーろ
ただ
すぐさま反撃に出るお笑い芸人チームん
これやバンドの鈴木大輔さんといいですねはいえええ
確かにこれ田村さんと分かりづらいそうなんですよぜひ田村さんをもうちょっと水通し
方ですねそうですね
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブービーもすごいいい
いやな最初だけたっていうふうにも ai なこっカット巻き返していかないとやばい
のでちょっともう
学です少し見られる名古屋じゃあスカジャン
さあ前半終えて21たい17ユーチューバーチームのリードで後半が始まりました
まず始めちゃうはいこの前半の戦いぶりというのを振り返っていただくと
いかがでしょうかそうですねまぁ4点勝ってるないでー
このを維持していければいいなと思いつつも入れば相手の選手もちょっとこう上手い人
が
いたりいなかったりするのでこちら前はまず
あの最初の後半冷蔵た方はい
+ば操作のチームレバー編成してなるほど増えておりましてあるぞー始めたじゃあ今出
ていない dqn てないよね
a
まあそれで内藤さん見て笑ってると思いまーそうですかよベンチで寝ない
さあさあさあ
向き目でいきました笑エニーチーム追い上げていきますこれで1点差
だですもう一ら後半
に主力また館倒れで
ああここ再び突き放しますねユーチューバーチームを受注するて付けますを得ないん
じゃねぇー
このメンバー編成がまあ同後半に響くかがポイントになると思いますねこの選手交代と
いうのも非常にポイントになってきそうですまだか寝笑い芸人チーム再び前線へという
ところです何個が奪い返してうちばチーム
ダンシャオのまま
明日5点差これでを使うチャージしましょう
a これで4翻訳遅刻はキャラになりました素晴らしいプレーでしたねはい綺麗なで
行ったでしたねー
さあ右サイドを使っていきますここはしっかりと守りたいん前につないでゴリゴリ秋冬
もう一度ああああそしてホイッスルデサールですねー
これで降り thrower
することになります iph 625第二重に決まれば2点差ということになりますし
こんなてぃですよブービー行きまーすっにょ全然大きなパス
このまま一旦ためて家の後ろそしてサビの位置から叡山から
もう一度
患者さん遠目から狙おうかというところですがもう一度パスをしてはしっかりペットで
責めちゃっていいかなとん
さぁさぁと繋いでいきます一般指導も使ってシュートを放っていきました
これが決まりませんもっと自分で取る
そしてもう一度ユーチューバーチームなんぞそれがさび止め望むかわいいバスだ
そして
これはまそてみー
岩井ませんでした今のは決定的なシーンでした
愛情たんですがじゃあさっきしました決まってましたマゾな木目労働ですから映画操作
決めました失礼しました27対22これでも再び5点参加
ビールを広げますユーチューバーチームやすいポイントです
にこれはかすりもしませんでしたこれ内藤さん他の会
少し高シュートの精度というのも落ちてきたかもしれません
そうですね版です
まあ我々みんな歳ですからねはいまあお笑い芸人さんも含めましておき厘差もまもなく
20周年という
はぐらいの芸妓とイラン人
感じですねファールですかねぇ
perl のあって5分白いが止まりますましたーーー
ユーチューバーボールですねはい
ただまぁこの感じね少しねあの体力を回復したいところですが
プーするえええファールするとパッケの試合で24秒で攻めなきゃいけないんですよ
はい
ためには16秒になってたみたいで a 厳しい審判があーもしっかりともーちゃん
ちょしていくというオールナイトさんどないでっしゃろさあこれで7点差にラリマー
水ですねー
しっかりと点差が開いてきましたね政治のリードに彼は降りつつあるでしょうか
ユーチューバーチーム
7点差守れるか後半です今の取りたいん
片鉾からとられて俺芸人チーム
追い上げられるかというところ後半強いですからね
さあこれが
4つません
救急隊22
炎上7点差レスがまだこの
後半も時間ありますので例えば笑チームですねえぇ笑い芸人チームウェイ
取れるかがだったさあここから
さらに点差を広げたい
しっかりと一定と全然この売り上げて夫あーすわー
声ごちゃごちゃしてしまいました運動座った
おいっすが
なりますこれはまた a
ふうにんするはですねフリースローになりましたはここまであの肇社長あの後半の出番
がまだないと言う
はいところですけども
何でもしっかり体さんついて来てるねー
多分たベラさんがはもう後半にちょっといかつい人たちだしてきそうな気がしてるん
ですよ
ああそうですか
さといいする決まりませんでしたまぁそこに対応してる頃始めたちょうど一旦温存と
そうですねいうことになりますねぇ
まあでレバー華麗なプレーを見せてくれるでしょう子供
そうしたいところでありますよねー
こんな年で体がどこまでも来たり早いそこにも注目ですね
また今年に入ってからまあ腹筋を年前に300回しているということでちょっと走るの
早いだったんですかそうですか
さてに強みも生かせるかという今後のこの非常に期待がかかります始めましょう
そして天井があまり動かなくなりましたねそうですね入って両者ともにシュートが
決まらない間たらしく会で決めたい
やはりここも跳ね返されて以前29対29と
29で22という点差出会い
全数で進んでいきます
外だから3位9位
ありませんさあここで切れるでずっと痛いですねー
さあ飛んはつながらない
そうね混ぜねぇもうここで
ドルが出てくるこれああいう厨房チームじゃぜひですねシルクロードカンター
弾みさと創造シューティングで全然
ただのチャンネルの店さんってええもうこれはもう試合を決めに行くとハイヤー
答えそれに合わせた相手も後退してきてるんですよですかほとんどあのー
面白いのスターティングメンバーのようなはい
今人乗ってきましたねーでクライマックスですね
さあこの後レス訪販も徐々に徐々にし時間が少なくなっていますはい
効果しっかり止めたいところですねで返り咲いてあって a 公演か本当に彼にこの
身長で何でしょうかそれとも奪って当たりましたカットしてから
素早い動きを見せています周りの選手そして透明から狙っていきましたまあ入れたら
かっこよかっただけですねー
tdm は夫とのカウンターで集められましたこれで再び5点差ですやったためラサ
しっかりと決めていきますね大事なところで
修造の精度高いものがあります夫始めちゃおう
これはちゃんとしてよねーそして紅一点縮められた分
そうもう一広げたかったところですねまぁ競ってしまいましたね
最後点差のまま続きます
ボールを経てくるがー
[音楽]
はじめしゃちょー
もう一度パス
サードリーグで仕掛けるそしてもう一度枝はじめ
決まらないハワイ4んカラー
彼ちょっとねぇ
これはだよお困りますがまたリードしてるんでね
そうですねすみ機に行く分には
良いのかも知れません範囲
ただここはもう一度笑 g のトーンば言われる訳サイドを重ねちゃっちゃないんです
よね頑張りますよね全然センスとッター
さあ
前に deicide 使うそしてもう一度始めた親をたやんってどうだ
ダイムラー
ああああああん
ファーストコッパで持った
チャペルで良いと思いますそしてリーダーしているんですが
ただまだクーマンさーん不可能な俺だけじゃなかったよねそうですねー
なかなかこの29点という点数になってからこの点数を入れられていないという
ユーチューバーチーム30点だよなかなか遠い
俺が出るたびにマイボール my bolt お互いのチームがケンカするんですねー
そうですから
そして頭痛がひっくり返ってえっと
ユーチューバーボールになりましたそうですがもうこの抗議に屈したというあの形に
なってしまいます
さあカウンターボールを入れていく at 相手に当たって上田
ロスがパティ行くああああコーナー
点差を広げることができないのがユーチューバーチームになっていますこの時間帯
やばいそうこれは
というそんながー
前線もう一度さあこれで30点台などは休みとなった
カウンター
そして右サイドを使うまいん
自分で言ってこのパス透明から
銀波ない
もう一度ネス笑い芸人チームになります音お互いもどかしい時間が続いてますねもう
早めに提出を入れたいところではありますがここも決まらない
もう一度輸注バー
死ぬ登り散歩ですねーそしてありました銅版画集場がしました
インサイドから願っていく jose
我々はいナイスですねーもう29点になってからしばらく経過していますがちょっとは
売ってるんですけどねぇ
やっぱバスケットいうのは勝利を打たないと点車入りませんから
うーんそうですねまたホール果敢に攻めてほしいとなってこれずに火が入ってほしい
ですね
と言ってる間に
ボールハンドがキープして始めた長からシルク
著
樋開落ち着こうと言ったところですよですね深いと点数を決めたいところです
したくないとこの集中はねなかなか決まっていませんのでリズムを変えた方がいいかも
しれません
止めから
珍しいシーンでしょうかまかんったボールしたから
中と話し身をよく見られましたが岡田山からうって言いましたからですが
我々は
キーボードを打つことが得意ですからはい数と y まま得意ではないのかもしれそう
ですかもうそっちに重きを置いてるぞ
かごにバスケをやっていったプレイヤーであっても今もうキーボード
会津戦闘メスば良い子はこれ
そのために入ってますからね
これは極まらないが日本のずっとこれもう一度シュート反する
これで3点差です
あー強くなってきましたよあぁそうですねこの勢いこの今流れでいい意味で言いますと
オーライ芸人の方がちょっと中に乗っているとでのこれもう2分
切ってますからねそうですねこれ危ない時間帯です山と加工
あとシュート1本入れたいところですね youtube はチームねー
[拍手]
voodoo 長そして noire よああーーヌーからデューイ突破
奪い返すとああいう邪道ですロスナイクッパ
うん区の遅いですからねああああそうですかぁだ土木やちょっと投げすぎましたね
たまらの前に大パス精度も落ちてしまったと
3点差ですねえこれ3点差というのは欧州と日本で逆転が可能です
3いってまぁ同然ですからねその同点シュート自慢だ
じゃあ3本でシュートが残り1分の時間帯で決まりました
あと1分ですよヤバイよこれこれはもう告げに決めた方が処理をされるかという
以外の時間帯ですねー
さあも鍵リングたチャンスへピカ玉でさあ始めたぞ前犠打を決めました
ザーン草超大事な大事な
31点名このまま逃げ切りたいです
な守るかさあユーチューバーたた春場所のもう一度攻めチェック税課でを狙いにいく
またコーヒーのことも結構限界なんですよあーそなぁちょっとだけどなぁ
フレイの精度を欠いています大そこで肺やタイマーで母もギリギリのところではい
ここに偉いというのはどんな所なんでしょえっとこう残り時間が少ないのでおそらくも
しっかりと2点取ればどうせんですから
はいどう手当てにとってくるか
3ポイントで逆転するか入る
狙い com でいこうとはいこちらは作戦会議中ですね
ね少し口を始めたというから映画を見られましたんですけどねぇカンタさんもう心臓が
表情してますねまぁ頑張ってくれますよ
さあ29対31残り28秒です
まあ実家もありませんさ肇社長が8秒左サイド飼育から始め社長
そしてカウンターさあ本当にをですよ実践時間を使おう
これ時間を使い切ってしまえば勝利です市場チームカウンター前に出たところ集計ある
しを守って
ああこれはあります成功を食べたい
シュート1本意見が笑 ag 名ここはカウンターが勝ったしますこれは2分になり
ました
あんたにカットしましたねぇー今回はカットしました
あったんですねも a 環境がカットで買ったですね浜簡単だして買ったすれば一番
いいんだけどね
またバイまたよねここでをダウンアウト
カウンターみたいノートですも度覗い次回の本当
難病なんでしょ a
具合などの終盤ですがタイガーと方手続きも市場生らん
神乳セイバーの母ほしい
いた部下はいますそれですね5万通と思いますってコーナーしちゃって第2つとも出し
たいか誰をつかめる取れちゃってだろう
阿部 hanihani 22つ予定している
さあの僕0
さあこれがもうラストワンプレーに何でしょうかはいえにチームボールから始めた
ところ必至の姫スってやつを出してそしてしるこディフェンス税増税やんって言った
これが決まらない
はぁああああああん
一周
[拍手]
me
よくがんばりました俺スプレー
嬉しいじゃないですかねぇは至極なくてセンセ5 ai
田辺社長でしたーー
青そうですああ
yeah
ai
展示によってもいいしたーー
どうですか
そうですねまさか収入なかけている言語をつけて勝った勝ったねー
ありゃしないん
いやーましたああああああ
ええええええ
[拍手]
3が目じゃない東ました窃盗
すごいおっ
ブーブー image
機会がありますよああ
うん
me